how you doing it me I'm doing good
how's the Godfather Hollywood doing
thanks to you over a million two hundred
thousand hits from our interview
unbeliever woman they love your story
they love your story you know everywhere
I go I was I went to restaurant about
when it was open I want to delq Frisco's
in Dallas this guy I go in there I move
my wife we're having dinner and the
valet guy comes in he says mr. bad AV
can I talk to you afterwards when you
leave oh yeah sure he says I follow your
content I said no problem
so I leave and he says can I talk to
privately I see yeah sure I can talk to
you privately cuz my wife was right
since I don't want to ask this question
in front of your wife I said short he
says do you really believe that Johnny
Russa hooked up with Marilyn Monroe when
he was 16
it's what he said he says Patrick that's
crazy if he did I said that's Gianni
Russo story for you so for some of me
that don't know my friend today Gianni
Russo Gianni was that when you were you
were running you were doing some stuff
for her Frank Costello is when you met
Marilyn Monroe when you were younger
yeah she was in New York City they were
hiding around actually from a zanuck
brothers in LA cuz she wanted to do
legitimate movies not just sexy comedies
and all of that and so she came here and
Costello put him in the Waldorf Astoria
for a year and she studied with Stella
had where she studied with everyone
because she wanted to become a
legitimate actress and they just wanted
to sell her as a sex bomb and I in I
babysat her for a weekend cuz Costello
was going to go fishing believe it or
not with Tony Accardo in Chicago and so
he could tell me who was up there so I
went to three knocked on the door and
she opens the door and she's in a
terrycloth throat and she met me what I
was champ
oh yeah Lily - Shay's the first time I
met her and then she started requesting
me so when she opened the door she what
are you doing here
that's well mr. C told me to keep an eye
on him for the weekend she's well come
on in
I said I can't come in get me Wyatt just
come on and I can tell him should I just
wanted room service have breakfast with
me I said I already ate breakfast thank
you so we ice it will then talk to her
so I'm gonna take a bath I socal gonna
go downstairs if you need me just call
the front desk
you all know the kid everybody know me
by the kid she's now stay here for a
while so she walks me by up what takes
my hand and walks me into the bathroom
turns this tub of water on so she said
brush out my hair for me I done that a
million times after I shampoo her so
she's sitting yeah she lowers the world
war four shoulders so I could call me a
throw so she said come get in the tub
with me
it's what are you gonna get me fired she
takes me by the hand to the tub she
drops her robe and gets into the tub now
understand I'm like 16 17 years old
this is Malin Monroe I just saw
something like it hot maybe 50 times and
I'm picturing her and she said come on
get in the tub so I'm in gentlemen all I
could say to your audience is that was
Saturday afternoon
I left Monday morning but today you know
we had a friendship for four years until
they killed him unfortunately you had a
you had a friendship with her for four
years oh yeah the only thing why she was
here at night when she went to the hotel
she'd call me and she'd put on a wig and
a disguise in fact we went to the subway
bar right here on 62nd Street in
Lexington she sat at the bar drinking
with me at night nobody even knows well
Monroe now you know when you see the
pictures when you see she was on the
cover the first Playboy year issue I
think it's 1950
nine or some issue like that it's a it's
a it's the first one with a Hefner
it may not be 59 I don't know the number
but I was about to buy the highest
graded version of her magazine for like
two hundred thousand dollars but she's
she's beautiful on the pictures that you
see when you see her movies on you know
all these different clips that come out
you saw her face to face how beautiful
was she you've seen a lot of woman in
your life how would you describe her
beauty you know what I liked about it
you know her and I had a comparison
because you know for my book when I was
a child I was quarantined in Bellevue
1914 I were polio and she had a similar
thing at 12 years old she was put in an
orphanage in the valley in California
and she always looked out the window at
the water tower of Warner Brothers and
said someday I'm gonna be there and I
only had a similar story because when I
finally got the window bed and I saw the
Empire State Building I said someday I'm
gonna be uptown so I wasn't a sexual
thing was a friendship but Mallett had
this floor I call it a floor and
personality because she just thought she
had a please every man she met and she
did it sexually I mean you name her love
is Sinatra brain though it named anybody
you want in fact I remember when she did
a last movie with what was his name made
major movie star and it was not his last
movie and they they coached the auditor
and they made love every day and every
when the movie wrapped in June he died
of a heart attack two weeks later and
she called me up on the phone so I
killed him I killed him and I screwed
you killed what was his name
major guy I want to say Rock Hudson or
somebody like that clog table but why
the point I'm trying to make is that was
her gift to mankind her body and it
happened obviously with John Kennedy and
then when John Kennedy told her once you
become president you
gonna leave Jackie and Merida that's how
naive she was his brother Bobby is
consoling her and impregnates her now he
already had so many kids with Ethel was
he going so I mean that's why when they
brought in a cal-neva the last time I
saw Sam Giancana brought her up there
because the deal late that Joe Kennedy
made with the mob is you get my son
president we're gonna invade Cuba
and that all fell apart a lot to do in
Bobby because Bobby and John never got
along they he didn't realize his brother
was this righteous guy and he was flying
for the the next day he is after John's
and they didn't realize the mob already
promised Lyndon Baines Johnson the next
eight years cuz the only reason Lyndon
Baines Johnson went along with Kennedy
because he hated the Kennedys was they
mean enough they made him that promise
and I remember going to Dallas where you
are and drove about 30 miles out
witnessed a suitcase that I knew was
full of money I went to this ranch and
left it and three days later he makes
the announcement that he's gonna be his
running mate and I said I can't believe
what I'm witnessing it's like insanity
but so they encouraged her to come up to
Cal neba
Costello said go be my izing is there
I'm not going near it and Joe Kennedy
showed up with Bobby and Sinatra and
Peter Lawford promised that they'd have
control of John and when he got into
office he even broke his friendship with
Sinatra
so Sinatra had to get Maryland Dan
they knew the Kennedys would show Joe
was already in a wheelchair that time he
had a stroke because they told him we're
gonna start killing off your kids and
Sam Giancana
and the Chicago Outfit felt really
insulted because Johnny shook their
hands on it and Joe Kennedy shook hands
on then they turned their back on them
so the last chance they had was to get
Marilyn up there they were gonna set
Bobby and
together in a room that cameras like
they did with J Edgar Hoover when they
blackmailed him in Chicago and a
cross-dressing party and they had all
these photos of Django with his gay
lover who had was his assistant in the
FBI agent in fact they've buried
together I mean this this stuff you
can't make god this is nuts but I was
there just three different Costello and
that Saturday
lady afternoon I think there's a bunch
of pictures of my my website and all
that um all of us together Sinatra
Marilyn and he told her that tonight she
has to do everybody a favor
meaning Costello oh god Oh everybody and
she said why we just want you to entice
BA because John didn't show the last
minute he can't and we want to take
photographs with you together we got a
blackmailing well she went crazy so I
want nothing to do with them because
nobody knew she just aborted Bobby's
baby
this girl was wounded man - I mean
mentally screwed up and she was
screaming screw these candidates I'm
going to the press and soon as she said
that we know a days were numbered I flew
back that Monday this was a Saturday
afternoon
I told Costello what she said and he
wanted to know who heard it and when I
told him he looked up at me I never said
he turned ghost white he said she just
wrote her death wish and sure enough two
days later she's dead man Wow these
stories I mean you hear these stories
you want how much of it is
uh-uh-uh-uh-uh
it sounds like pure Hulk foot and it's a
real story that you share them with the
rest of us but do I know a lot of people
that probably would have my job having
to babysit you babysit Marilyn Monroe
it's a pretty nice job oh yeah I had a
couple of good jobs in my career I'm 77
years that's a that's that's a pretty
that's a pretty interesting one that's a
pretty interesting one
you and I were talking you said
something about polio like you
experienced a pandemic before so what
are your thoughts with what's going on
right now and then in the past well you
know it's so wild that you bring that up
because I've been asked that numerous
times just recently because of that and
the people who are aware of the book it
opens with me
August 7th 1949 going into Bellevue and
I was quarantined and what kid at 6 7
years old
even those what the word means and that
was August and my birthday was
approaching and a candy striper who
happened to be calling and Minos niece
said look after this kid he's from the
neighborhood and thank God for her that
I have my sanity if I really am saved I
don't know I'm sane or not but what
sanity I have I attributed to Delores
Barone because she'd bring me the extra
jello or that hug but I was there the
first three years part of the experiment
for Joel Jonas Salk and took three years
I hope the vaccine for this one doesn't
take three years because that's a living
hell and I watched 2,700 kids die it was
insane but fortunately wake quarantine
now seven years later and I walk out of
my apartment I go to Central Park and I
walk in the park
I'm not confined to a bed in a mental
institution so this this quarantine is I
think a lot more serious because it's
such an unknown virus but as we all know
now through the news and I watched your
interview yesterday even that they have
it I think they're gonna have this cured
right away and but I think politics as
usual is getting in way of that too
because they want to suppress truck
whinny again to November so I think
they're gonna dragged us out to the
economy don't go back cuz if the economy
goes back I think he's in for another
four years how are things right now New
York and when you're going out are they
are they on you are they stopping you
how are things in New York well New York
cities as we
those worst-hit but I live on 61st
Street I walk down a couple of blocks
I'm in Central Park and I don't have to
worry about social distance thing this
is nobody on the street all the doormen
that I know cuz I make a right and go
uptown I do about five miles a day I'll
go up fifth and come down walk I feel
very safe about it because there's
nobody on the street I have a face mask
fortunately and I'm very healthy I eat
well I sleep 10 12 hours a day and as I
pointed out and I'm 77 and I my last
major disease was polio so just stay in
that alone I have no respiratory
situations I'm not overweight I don't
have diabetes and these are all the
symptoms as we're hearing or basically
the older people who have this I'm old
but I have no diseases but it's took
it's taken a toll on a lot of my friends
and I lost the nephew at 41 where
they're already so I mean I hope it ends
soon just so we can get back to some
kind of normal tea but who knows what
that's gonna be what do you what do you
think's happening to your friends I'm
Hollywood right now I mean obviously
you're in that world you have friends in
that world how is Hollywood gonna adjust
with this now that they're gonna do you
know movie theatres are not gonna be
sell out with 500 people in a movie
theater how are they gonna pivot
well I guys funny because I I have my
book is in development right now and we
just got a big break this week because
as we started seeing all these streaming
networks like the Irishman went to
limited run in theatres just to get
qualified I think you're gonna see more
of that mm-hmm
you know what I'm thinking I mean I had
the wireless conversation with a
philanthropist in New York City who's
just investing more I see you should
stop buying the parking lots of shopping
malls is what are you talking about as
well the brick-and-mortar you can do
nothing but I I think anybody that opens
up like GMC drive-in theaters where
people are comfortable in their own
all bring their own food but it's still
a way to entertain your kids and
whatever I think these are gonna be the
new ways of going I don't think people
gonna go sit if I were to thin it I
don't need to go to restaurants too soon
either well let me ask you when the
polio happened when seven years ago how
soon did it get back to normal you said
three years for vaccine you know think
faster right now
how long did it take to people are like
I'm just back to normal life I didn't
know because I'm just in the hospital
for five years so I'm not the kind of
and it's not like we were watching
television there wasn't even televisions
in our room but I mean you know anything
I can do like anybody else has go to the
history books and it until they got that
back steam and slowly opened up again
but I don't hear like I'm personally for
my own sake listen to all the news
they're always mentioning the Spanish
flu and all the other major epidemics
and the death but you know I don't the
economy is what more all I'm worried
about is what people know victimized by
that we got thirty million people out of
work and those jobs are not opening
those mom-and-pop restaurants I they
work paycheck to paycheck yeah it's
gonna be interesting to see what happens
there by the way back in the days did
you did you take on a base to drive in
Luzerne oh did you go a lot of your uh
your bra's your girl your friends or no
you know what happened Stello
i jumped my whole dial adolescence I
became a man so fast traveling the world
and I really didn't go to drive-ins and
all that like wait I went from 14 or 15
years old to getting involved with the
elections in 1960 which now is 18 and
I'm you know I'm flying all over the
world
staying in every hotel meeting every
mobster every entertainer
you know team water all these guys
became my friends when most people were
playing baseball
cowboys and Indians but yeah I'm having
the experience to go to the Copa which
is on 60th Street I
to walk in there that's where I met
Sinatra finally after listening to him
on the radio every day when I found the
his birthday in mind is the same so I
walk in he's having a sound check at 4
o'clock in the afternoon
and I'm 15 years old so he motions to
truly bow down he says who's this kid
like without saying anything he said
don't worry about it
he's that's Costello's boy when he said
that's the first time I've ever heard I
thought that was six foot tall so I sat
down there was rehearsal and soon as he
broke for the rehearsal I went right
over he was just won another cigarette
in his mouth and I lit it for him and I
said Frank you don't realize you saved
my life
oh yeah how they do that I said well I
had polio 94 I told the whole story and
they came in little transistor radio and
I realized December 12th is your bird in
mind so he saw my boat's address I see
yeah he's what you made I said the kid
who gave me that name it's mr. C he's
the big guy yes the wrong question well
did he have the biggest personality out
of anybody who ever met oh yeah I think
he go why so many others wasn't more
heuristic oh but the Frank liked you he
likes you but you know and if you're a
good friend of his you know when he gets
drunk lead he's a bad drunk you like to
fight though he was six but for somebody
I've seen him pick fights with people
that you know he tried that once with me
trying to smack me and I grabbed the
song I was like 17 right the sands hotel
and I said try that again and I can't
say what I told him but I tried to get
it I'll rip off your arm and shove in
someplace and you looked at me looked at
Julius what's he gonna do and then he
looked around the room and Mickey Cohen
was sitting there was running a hotel he
says right you picked on the wrong guy
he think your head off he once there and
though he's been Apple we became friends
that minute from that point how much of
that was just because people knew you
were with
mr. C well you know I got to be I think
they heard a rumba how I got out of the
hotel - and then your long with
everybody I'm in the hospital and and
the people I was around you know the
Sibel is out I know every major family
in the world was hello from New Orleans
you know and they there was a mystery
about me of why all these guys like me
well I'll tell you if I wasn't doing
their errands and paying a hundred
percent of their money to them all the
talking I would have been liked either
but I grew you know a great respect and
for many years you know I was there
under Stalin for 20-some years so
20-some years yeah
did you get a chance to see the
interview with leonetti no you know I
Leonetti to me I know of him you know
he's gonna have a nice car for these
guys I mean I mean remember I used to go
down there when they were building big
city because landing city was controlled
by the Gambino's and as we all know the
Gambino's control construction in new
york and concrete and everything else
but most lay people don't realize you
can't truck ready mix country from New
York to Atlantic City so they had to use
Philadelphia and all the union's that's
how they got so strong so I think they
they have a big problem and I mean I
heard something leonetti's statements he
better be living in an armored truck
look how they took out all the other
guys
very creative
Philip was a different story very
creative no face to face unity came out
here we spend he was with me for a day
and a half I was gonna say I'm hope he
came to you yes he came over here and it
was very interesting we had dinner the
night before at an Italian restaurant
just to kinda
spend some time together and get to know
to see the level of comfort and then
after that we knew was going to be
easier to follow and he just didn't want
to show his face but I can tell you when
I when I when I asked the question about
South test down and I showed the picture
of South test he wasn't comfortable with
it he got to see that part he swiped the
page immediately when I put tests that's
pictured there and he got emotional so
it was it was interesting seeing
I mean I've interviewed a lot of
controversial figures he created a lot
of frenzy what a lot of people come
contact me many people weren't happy
about me sitting down with Sammy you
know that Samuel was not that there were
a lot of happy people about that but
this one got a lot of weird emails from
Philadelphia which was interesting
that's why he's going published now I
mean I don't see the benefit of it
you know he's he's made enough money and
if anything go out in the Sun setting go
out of my boat I used to man
thanks sanctuary on my boat for years I
could be gone for two years three it's
till things you know blew over but I
don't know why especially you I shall I
mean that show thank God the visibility
you have you made me a hit and your
story here if you guys haven't watched
Johnny's interview if you I'm telling
you if you want to be entertained for an
hour and a half go listen to Gianni
story your net it's non-stop filled
we're not gonna go through all of them
today but is your stories are
one-of-a-kind one of the chorus about
their search you know it's what's
happening like this remember Allah you
know it's you're ready I'm ready and it
takes to you I consider it do it saying
nothing right you just lead me to what
we have to do and do it no I mean it but
again I think because of you my book is
a best-seller in seven
you opened the door to me and I think
this is why now I have the Netflix and
now who's thrown their hat in this week
which you know it's a thing where I do
business but my company does business
with paramount Viacom in my food and
liquor I'm the ambassador to the brand
but never thought that it'd be
interested in taking my book and
streaming it now Nick valano who won the
Oscar for Best Picture and Best
Screenplay green book he already wrote
the pilot and the sketch for the ten
hours this is the I mean and then he got
mark Anton who did the original cap God
good fellow
he's my executive producer with Colin
Wilson who just streamed Star Wars for
Disney and comes from Avatar Fame I mean
this team is like my lawyers even say to
me how do you get these guys I didn't do
anything they read the book they heard
the interviews and now why accom hired a
close friend of mine and a friend of my
business partner Jeffrey - to run that
whole division this is how my life goes
so now we're gonna have ten hours of my
book and now they're talking about my
podcast because the stories on the
podcast keep going I got 72 hours
recorded already but that's that's a lot
of people and how come you don't have
YouTube channel what some people don't
know it's you know Janak podcast instead
of YouTube channel Johnny I ask you
about the biggest personality you said
Frank Sinatra who had the biggest ego
ever you're gonna run all of them with
the biggest ego out of all of them well
the when I first met him and then just
as he got busted out of the Army in fact
he did a special at nobody knows this
for my olanski who owns the
Fontainebleau they filmed a lie - guys
Sinatra and Elvis Presley you got to get
that one
but I stayed friends with Elvis for a
long time but I had a nicest guy in the
world but man he's he controlled it all
and he knew it I mean women would go
crazy
I mean I know like you pointed out I've
been around angle Birds a good friend of
mine Tom Jones when he was hey Dana this
guy never seen a girl like this when he
walked and the fact that he was in the
Army I mean he did everything so right
to build his image and he's a great
southern boy you know there's a lot of
them out there but he can't istic aliy I
think the worst egotistical guy I met
had the pleasure of working with and he
wound his careers James Caan well you
like are issued yeah the two of you guys
went at it regularly
oh yeah we still don't know maybe Jimmy
Caan thinks when he left at that stage
he was sunny totally own talk about a
method actor Wow Wow
but that happens to a lot of people that
happens I hear it happens to a lot of
people when they do a part it stays it
doesn't change Yeah right well you know
what is I think that gave him the most
recognition prior to that was Brian
piccolo that movie thing he did it was a
great story but this gave him he always
wanted to be a mob guy his father was a
butcher in the Bronx I don't know if you
notice he's from the neighborhood but
you know he went to all private schools
and Stella Hadley study with everybody
as the thespian this came a different
recognition they came neighborhoods he
could walk into he made friends I mean
he may look where he made friends many
Allie boy they made friends with every
mobster there was and they loved him he
would go to trial with her on trial and
said the trial I mean this guy like
Nicky Roth was that way when Mickey
Rourke he went to every Gotti trial when
God he went to jail you know he sent him
a treadmill they will live you sent him
a treadmill exam yeah
in fact you know funny a part of trivia
to show that the strength of Gaudi we
went to a movie called striptease with
Demi Moore and it was one of three
pictures I did from Michael LaBelle and
Andrew Bergman and I got a nice guy who
I really like I'm on a Sunday was on in
the movie and he gets a call from HBO
where they wanted him to play John Gotti
in the HBO movie which he did - and he
was so funny so I can't do that that's
what he talking about is thank you
I just wanna thank your permission from
him it's how you do that I said well
don't wear gun if I get permission will
you do it so yeah so nobody knew John
Gotti
John had a prison guard game a phone his
phone for an hour a night so he calls me
through my friend John Joe Watts and I'm
on the set I told you what time to call
he calls and I said come on there's a
phone call here with John Gotti he said
I found out they asked you to do play me
it would be my pleasure for you I'm a
big fan he owes you a good-looking guy
do the movie that's when he did the
movie you can't tell people these
stories that's like insanity
how much striptease by the way was was
that at Demi's peak looks-wise or was
there was her ready for indecent yeah I
GI Jane judging know she but I tell you
I had such fun with her and they asked
me which is the greatest job in the
world talking about having to drop the
baby said Matt Monro I maybe sit here in
New York cuz she wanted to go to strip
clubs to see how they really live and do
who's that tell me about Demi Demi Moore
wanted to go to strip clubs to see how
they did how did it get into your head
you know it's like a character study so
I had a convenience to myself I put it
down here
and to Regency my friends the petitions
on it and everybody stayed there I mean
I put millions of people in it so we get
a sweet [ __ ] and so now I tell wanna
brothers you gotta give me like 2500 at
night this is why I finally can use
credit card to the board I don't have
any I don't want any never did I said
what he need the money by says she wants
her is probably have that cash to get to
these strippers you watch to know what's
going on so making yummy I'm a
businessman so now I go to Warner
Brothers obviously and they give me a
draft that I get you know twenty five
hundred dollars every time you went out
so I call the clubs and I knew everybody
hold them and to listen I want a bi
peopled all your house money because
they give you a fake money you know and
I'll bring Demi Moore in they should
kidding me so I was making money on both
how was the reaction when she went there
how was she what's she watching and like
was she enamored by she was in that so
enamored by that we had to put a pole
before anybody knew about poles in her
room in the suite and now she's inviting
these pros to show how to do it
Wow we actually took three or four girls
from New York to Florida where we shot
that there were problems they were there
the alidium felt bad about that you
being a parent you may understand it I
hate her understand how Bruce Willis let
his daughter play his mother's the
daughter in this movie because she was
exposed and the eight and nine year old
kid backstage with all these hookers and
then the foul-mouthed even the mother
and this is really a mother doing a
striptease I know they were ever the
same how can that justify but no Bruce
Willis huh why would he say get an
actress I don't need my daughter doing
this hmm but you know I've seen what
you're in that world you know you don't
you do it's it's a very interesting
world that world is I can tell you one
thing I watched
Indecent Proposal bottle phenomenal
soundtrack
with Sade no ordinary love I mean she
crushed it I think that movie is with
that song but I watched that movie
probably fifty a hundred times with the
whole scene with Robert Redford and
woody and the arguments and how she
looked and it was just a I think I think
that movie Demi Moore at that time she
may have been topped by most beautiful
woman in the world if you know she'll
movie I don't know was a last time you
watch that movie if you sit there you
watch that movie it's it's it's it's
like God did sculpture with that body
well I tell you right now we had a
40-foot semi on under set every day with
her trainers it was a gym a portable gym
just for her that girl worked out four
hours a day
I mean weights everything I watched her
and him trying to get a visual on this I
watched her to a hand stand behind her
normal chair a regular diamond chair and
lowered herself into it backwards you
know an arm strength and I mean let's
see what I think about you you brought
this up I think about how many women I
seen do these crazy things that and and
not household names it's crazy that's
the life of Gianni Russo man the life of
Gianni Russo there isn't you need a
month to tell all the stories you've had
you know your stories it's 70 70 is it
done change every day is another story
what do you tell a young man that wants
to be good with a woman what tipped you
get on Stingo doesn't want to get
married he doesn't have a lot of game
how does the improve his game that's a
good question I think for the right
teacher Ford Li I tell you first of all
I think why I was always so well
accepted I was wearing polite and net
manners
I opened doors for women that's gone
chivalry is gone and if you think you're
much of my not having it you're gonna be
playing with yourself a long time
[Laughter]
so so what was swipe right during in
your times well I think you know there
was a mystique about me because of the
people I was around I can't take credit
for it but I definitely stay groomed
well groomed dressed again was very
courteous and you know made a woman feel
like a woman that's the whole thing most
men today want to satisfy themselves
first and think they're gonna move on
well you know you get a reputation to
that and the pleasure making love to
some of the greatest women in the world
and and being friendly with Grace Kelly
talking about a beauty Ava Gardner I
mean these people you know at nighttime
we go to the swimming pool at Jack and
trotters place in Nevada and there's to
call them the mascots we all heard about
the rat on the Rat Pack but they
actually had mascots and yet they had to
be tested and grouped and the mascots
like Angie Dickinson the only one that
was confused but I know why they let her
language so talented was Judy Garland I
would never want to see Judy all the
nude again don't want to say that I saw
her in a paid search on any it was like
skin and bones look at the boy but now
gimme the know then round Monroe's they
Eve a goddess even chillier Prowse she
was a great dancer I don't know how many
people would know her but she was a
headliner at the Desert Inn Hotel
interesting yeah but it's a interesting
world out there
fortunately your club when you ran into
big estates was it called State Street I
think it was Stan Smith hates me
well the one before that was Tiffany's
Costello all nobody knew that to
Costello and Joe Kennedy on the
Tropicana Hotel years ago and when I
went out they said cuz he need to create
something for me he wanted me to open a
club and I opened it in the Tropicana
Hotel this is this club operated 18
hours a week only
six hours from midnight Thursday night
to Friday morning six hours Friday to
Saturday morning six hours Saturday
night to Sunday woman eighteen hours got
Elvis Presley and Sammy Davis to open it
up for me they had all the cab company
so if you got into camps I want to go to
Caesars Palace now you gotta go to this
new club Tropicana and then I don't then
I had to open the bigger club but I'd
leave Vegas you know statute of
limitations are over so oddly Vegas on a
Monday morning when all the skim I
hadn't go back to Chicago
it's in New York I had the greatest
cover how was it how was the club when
it was at its peak I mean what did it
look like what was it like how amazing
was it first of all I get calls like
this like Don Rickles would call from
the Riviera and his valet we see Don
wants his table I said well that table
tonight
Paul Anka's in it he's how about the day
well they knew the place how about the
table near the fireplace as well right
run walk baby every night somebody else
in 10:15 movie stars because I served
gourmet food from 6:00 at night to 6:00
in the morning so that was the gimmick
because after they did me a second show
one o'clock
you would think you're at the edge
Sullivan show there was so much
entertainment in my club Engelbert
Humperdinck came in one night when part
of his band it did two hours till Sun
came up you never knew what was gonna
happen there that kind of a club but
then you're like that
situation after eight years that ended
habit do you come out the guy Pablo
Escobar's guy from the mid-eighteen that
changed the game that was can't you you
know I was ready though time for to get
into time for it though right yeah you
know why because I try to change what I
do personally every seven years my
loyalty to what I was doing is still
ongoing but uh
but that's all which they don't need
anybody but the accounts and waiting do
thinks that it's all changed everything
that's me now it changes I just wish I
knew what was gonna happen go to save
more money did you ever have any run-ins
with Hugh Hugh Hefner did you do
anything with them or no all we knew who
you are yeah I did a lot of things
unfortunately again because of Chicago
you know impacting for that and the
right after I did the Godfather they
gave me this dog an assignment any
singer in the world would die for
there's got him we want you to start up
in Rochester New York
they opened clubs Playboy Clubs
everywhere I would sing Thursday find
insanity to Playboy Club Sunday I'd
leave with a couple of buddies and
drives to the next state and do that
that's what I did I did that all the way
to century city in California across
country so I called I called New York
Rolls Royce they to look at me a new
Cornish white white on white February 2
I drove that car myself across the
country dropping off money so Sears they
used to rotate bunnies nobody knew that
so you remember you had different girls
and that's how they did that with strip
clubs people don't know that because
they rotate the girls and that's why my
a friend that we know of Jack Ruby
that's when he ran for Chicago so I
learned all that is from them so I took
club I took all these things I did this
with my cocktail waitress I'd rotate
them to a common New York or like I went
when Jack Nicholson had the monkey bar
I'd send girls come work the monkey by
us I mean no girls so it's always fresh
meat as we would say hello Monroe
babysitter you were also a bunny
babysitter oh yeah a lot of them a lot
of rabbits my gosh I mean it's a batter
what do you think about what's going on
right now you
you've been around you've seen a lot of
different things how much of this stuff
are you seeing right now and what do you
think is gonna happen next with
experiences you've had
well I know I think as we all experience
that I don't think every penny if they
want to open restaurants I don't think
the customers are coming so open it but
hello and yeah I heard an interview in
New York City last night where they got
only 50 percent capacity they better
hope they get 25 percent
tour saying well I can't open I have to
have all my tables and chairs unless I
can't make money
well you ain't make any money now so
they're gonna give you a stimulus
package we can make 25 cents read the
Randhawa take the 25 cents I think a lot
of I'm just gonna walk away you know
they can open up Dallas on Friday and my
wife was calling all the restaurants she
was calling Capital Grille she's Colin
Fleming she's calling all these other
ten minutes yeah she's calling Capital
Grille all these other places Capital
Grille that the entire schedule with the
tables they have one hour all sold out
all of them Wow every single one of them
yeah you know I had the privilege of
being in Dallas about a year and a half
ago before I met you I opened Turco
there that Club hmm
you know it's from serous Turco is a
spinoff of the circuit New York so I
opened it there right on that corner
we're a poolside club a nightclub I was
here for the whole weekend I love Dallas
I have a lot of those actually it's
gonna be interesting to see how it is
when they open this thing up I'm
actually really curious myself